[Music]
episode of hustle and Athena rocket
Allah
captain miranov
Qatari long that's an understanding in
the future
[Music]
there is any yeah I want a coffee date
efficient without
my dad is under Nate with the grace of
God and Mohammed said in one moment
article married I just been told when he
got married and he told she was the best
lady in the world and he you can't find
anybody better than that I can only
recall 1969 when it came to this country
my dad was working woman mail that time
there were melts everywhere grandfather
like a gold mine now all the industry in
Bradford died and all the building now
is empty it's a like a data Lake and
this is sad story but that's how much
it's changed in you know since 1969 to
2015 like that they really kind and it
just gives courage money to do whatever
we wanted is in Punjabi se pehle Nam
Kidada that mean number one is a God
second is your parent you know between
me my wife and my sister we lived
together and look after them
[Music]
[Music]
I'll demand American burger in Canberra
Mottola misurkin are making a girl just
a bad job start the waxer we have got
big family my mum and dad got eight
children and twenty six grandchildren
and twenty seven great-grandchildren
their wisdom is God gifted to us when we
make a decision we will talk to mom and
dad and I involve both my kids and we
all sort of contribute before we make
any decision so all the decision is made
in a family when we celebrate like a
birthday we do every year when you can
pass a hundred-plus
that is very very important you have a
look at Easter and you want to even find
a car 409 years old you've got to make
sure you got to stick it 1:09 and into
up to 70 is fine but when you cross the
bridge over hundred it is very very
important to my family
[Music]
to us Oh mom and dad we said all models
we look at them our children look at us
so if he can look after our mom and dad
hopefully my children look after me and
their children look after them
[Music]
[Music]
we are so proud of our mum and dad the
work hard they came here and they look
after healthy educated us there is
teachers nurses doctors and it's all
because of my mum and dad work hard and
what they didn't had they given to us
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah I've got another hole
you gonna hold I'm Tim berry day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]